puis un jour on a fait une démonstration
sans fil c'était le 14 avril 1931 entre
montrouge et l'école supérieure
d'électricité malakoff
seuls ces photos témoignent de l'exploit
technique le 14 avril 1931 il ya tout
juste 90 ans et pour la première fois en
france une image et retransmise par
émetteur à la télévision cette invention
c'est l'oeuvre de l'ingénieur rené
barthélémy des milliers de spectateurs
se sont pressés pour assister à cette
première
la presse avait eu vent de cette
présentation l'avait annoncé et en
définitive dans une salle fait pour 300
personnes ont défilé en 3 séances 3000
personnes devant la caméra
la collaboratrice de rené barthélémy
suzanne bridoux qui fait office de
présentatrice des années plus tard en
la scène est reconstituée à la
télévision sur la chaîne de la rtm
messieurs c'est un très grand honneur
pour moi d'avoir à présenter la radio
vision ce soir à douchy-les-mines hautes
personnalités
la comédienne fait des démonstrations
pour tester la qualité de l'image
elles se maquillent fument et parle je
suis dans le noir absolu je vois tourner
devant moi un disque lumineux
extrêmement brillant presqu'île luis aux
quelques années plus tard nouvel exploit
technique cette fois sous l'impulsion de
georges mandel ministre des ptt
le 26 avril 1935 pour la première fois
une émission est retransmise à la
télévision française
là aussi
seuls ses rares photos témoignent de
l'exploit commenté en 1961 par un
journaliste le 26 avril 1935 très
exactement une première démonstration 60
lignes a eu lieu aux ptt rue de grenelle
on retrouve monsieur lamblot derrière
une caméra et de l'autre côté de la
caméra il y avait et béatrice brethes et
béatrice bréti actrice et compagne du
ministre se charge de la présentation
pendant 10 minutes
elle raconte son voyage en italie des
années plus tard en 1961
l'actrice revenait sur cette expérience
télévisuelle on avait prié m'asseoir sur
une chaise qui avait été très exactement
cadres et on avait bien recommandé de ne
pas faire des gestes trop véhément selon
mon habitude de manière à ne pas
déborder du petit écran dans les années
seuls quelques dizaines de récepteurs
existe en france il faut attendre la fin
des années 60 pour que les postes de
télévision commencent à se généraliser
[Musique]